接着咱们说配角，好吧，主角说忘了说配角。
所一说配角。
配角啊。
他是第一次讲。
为啥？
之前好几次有些同学问这个配角的事儿，都被我拦住了。
早太早了。
聊什么配角啊？
对不对？配角用你创造吗？配角不是咱们创造的。
配角不要着急，上节课我说了，配角从事儿上来。
我非常反对有一种写法，那种写法就是初学者容易容易犯的错误。
你说让他写一个故事，写一个剧本。
他先写人物小说。
谢谢我这个男主角是一个什么样的人？
他以前经历了什么？
他那现在有一些什么呢纠葛，什么叫纠结？我这女主角是个什么样的人？这没问题。然后呢开始写我这个呃这个这个对手这个坏蛋是一个什么样的人？这个坏蛋，他媳妇儿是又是一个什么样的。
我这个男主他弟弟是一个什么样的？男主他同学对吧？男主他妈。
我这女主的闺蜜啊呀，是一个啊呀，表面很很nice，其实内心有点险恶的女人。
对吧。
然后呢，我的这个谁谁谁，我隔壁这个邻居又是一个什么样的人？
就来这一套写的很过瘾。
你喜欢干什么？
配角不需要你去设计，你就给我写一个主角。
配角。
从哪产生配角的产生？
我上节课说我，从事儿上来。
对吧。
事儿上来。
从什么事儿上来？
从序列的事件群中来。
也就是说你进展到这个序序列的时候，进展到转折。
事件。
你这里需要一个来一个什么样的配角，那你就在这里写。
配角在序列中依次出场。
他带着功能出场。
我们说第一场戏。
在路边摊。
吃烧烤晚上嘛吃烧烤喝酒。
我需要有，然后去遇到了小流氓欺负。
呃，这个烤串的这一这一对。
可怜的小夫妻。
那么来来那几个小流氓。
啊，可怜的小夫妻，这不就是配角吗？
他不就在这里自然而然的出场了吗？
你因为你你你在这里需要这样一个事件。
呃，需要有人承担这样的功能，需要有人欺负人，需要人被欺负。
然后就在这里出场。
然后你在这里说上，你就可以在这里设计，那他既然要被欺负，我最好让他可怜一点，对吧？想想哎呀，这个呃这个女女你一对夫妻嘛，一对夫妻那要可怜，那在在在在在旁边在。
再来个小孩吧，穿这个快裆快裆裤在旁边玩泥巴。
对吧？
然后呢，这这对夫妻，然后这个老婆呢比较勤快，也比较会说话。得得考虑这个招揽生意嘛，所以说。
对任何人都笑脸相迎。然后呢，那个老公呢。
呃，呃，不太吱声。
可能是因为觉得家庭的重担把他压的对吧？后来呢我发现还少一条腿，因为可这个这个是个退伍军人，那么你在到那个时候，你再去设计。
因为他扛着功能出来。
你再去设计他是他是干啥的？
所以配角的产生。
是在你写序列事件的时候。
带着功能依次出场。
这是配角的产生方式。
然后。
等你把序列群写完了之后。
你继去看带着功能出厂的配角，可能是有30个，也可能是有40个、50个，对吧？然后进行第二步工作，叫配角的整理。
配角如何整理呢？
第一步。
合并。
革命啊。
按照功能出场的配角，那基本上是每一个序列就出一个出这些呃配角都是存在在每个序列里面。
是需要给他进行合并的。
功能差不多的。
属性差不多的职业差不多的合并成一个人。
合并成一个人。
这样的话可以让他在。
序列里面存在的时间尽量变长。
就是。
退觉的合并问题。
为什么要合并？
我们说配角的合并。
是什么原则呢？就是功能相近的配角进行合并，这样可以让你的配角减少少而精。因为原则上配角其实是越少越好。
而且配角出现在序列中是越长越好的，他尽量跨多个序列。
这样的是你的序列你的配角才会有变化，它会也会有成长。
你之前按照功能从事儿上来的配角，那他肯定是单个序列里面出现。
对不对？
所以说第二步。
做配角的整理工作。
主要。
就是进行合并。
从功能上。
相同或者相似的都可以进行合并。
然后第三步。
叫配角的加强。
我们说配角啊，他又不是主角。
呃，需要加强吗？也需要的，当然需要。
配角如何加强呢？配角加强遵循的这个。
呃，遵循的这个这个这个个原则呢，就是增强配角的记忆点。
因为它相对篇幅少。
而且呢扛的责任呢要比较明确。
所以你在配角设计的时候。
着重考虑增强他的记忆点。
书上教材上对这。
在对这个增强配角的记忆点啊，有一个口诀，叫给配角戴上眼罩。
给配角戴上眼罩，什么意思呢？就是那种海盗的那个眼罩呀，一只眼。
这是一种很古老的提法。
因为很多教材啊是。
是很古老的说法。所以。
他当时考虑的呢，其实就是从身体上。
去找一个记忆点。
所以会出现什么戴眼罩的呀，瘸子呀，对吧？结巴呀。
这个呃那个乡村爱情最最典型里面所有的角色基本上都人手一个重大缺陷。
像残联。
是吧，而且你说缺陷明显缺陷就那么多。
都不够分的。所以乡村爱情里面光嘴不好的得有七八个。
结巴的一堆一堆的。
对吧大舌头结巴。
这种方法呢就比较。
叫老派。
而且呢。
从残疾下手啊。
其实是有点。
从这些年的审美来讲。
是有点low的。
我们尽量就不要去。
这么做了。
那么呃。
避开这个。
这个残疾。
下手。
我们如何加强？
配角的。
呃记一点呢。
那就是我说的。
你这个缺陷呀。
不一定要是身体上。
可以是坏习惯。
坏行为。
这你参考主角的这种这个这个这个可信度这里处理处理方式。
评委。
一个有强迫症的校长。
有学生到他房间来。
他有强迫症。
每次这个。
这个呃你不能动他桌上的东西，然后你每次他跟你谈完话，出去之后关上门呢，他都要过来再关一下。
你这种缺陷。
这种层面的缺陷。
就会相对高级一点，至少从这二年的这种审美来。
你永远去呃呃这是你的所有的配角不是瘸子，就是瞎子，然后还有三个磕巴。
还有一个是赵四那。
这个就。
我不推荐好吧，我不推荐这么去处理。
所以配角这里咱们就讲这么多。
产生从事儿上来，从序列世界上一个一个的产生，扛着功能产生，没有功能就别来。
然后呢，出来全部出来以后进行一个合并整理。
功能相近的。
相同相近的对吧？进行合并。你说这个人是出来，有一个人是出来给主角捣乱的。
但是呢他在这一场里面。
是一个看自行车的。
然后下一场呢又有一个人。
出来给主角捣乱，但是这一场的一来，我写了一个。
呃，是一个炸油条的。
但是你琢磨琢磨你哎呀这个炸油条的和那个看自行车的完全可以合并的。
那就给他合并。
原则是因为是配角越少越好。
而且在故事线里面存在的时间越长越好。
然后第三步就是对主对配角进行加强。因为配角。
我们讲纸片化的人物。
他这个身上不扛线的。
你要让观众记住他啊，你咋记？
就是给他。
戴个眼罩。
这是配角。
主角和配角。
啊，都讲完了，我们接下来讲一讲。
人物关系。
这个。
在我们。
剧本创作中。
是非常关键的。
叫人物关系。
人物关系啊。
呃，人物关系我们必须是用图形来表达的。
啥叫人物关系？
就是以主角为中心。
以主角为中心。
配角围绕在主角周围。
然后连接他们之间的。
是。
配角对主角的作用力。
配角对主角的作用力啊。
一般来说啊。
两条线，一条是他们之间的关系。比如说这个是主角的小舅子。
小舅子太太难写了。
那小梳子。
小叔子主角是男的是吧？
主角的弟弟。
对吧。
那这是他俩的关系。
所有力呢？
作用力呢？
作用力是什么作用力呢？
主角的故事线当中想办什么事儿？
比如说想抢银行。
主要要办的事儿。
那他弟弟是帮他。
关了。
对吧那就是是对他的。
主事件提供正向作用力。
帮助你的。
对吧。
然后呢，这个比如说是主角的女朋友。
对吧他跟主角的关系是男女朋友，但是呢他对于主角想抢银行这件事儿。
他可能是个告密的。
那他就是对主角主动力起反作用力的那个人。
所以这个人物关系图。
这个作用力指的是与你主角。
但行动力。
是推进。
还是阻碍就这两种。
当然不一定是只正着帮你推，有可能是斜着帮你推一推。
有是可能斜着阻碍你一下，但必须要么是推动，要么是阻碍。
这就是人物关系图的意思，就是这些配角啊对你跟你主角的关系是什么？
对于你主角主动想办的那件事儿。
啊，是推动还是阻碍什么样的推动是什么样的阻碍？
这个就叫。
人物关系图。
那么说还有一种是说人物关系图就是以主角为原心，就是这样吗？当然了，配角与配角之间他俩还有关系呢。比如说弟弟跟女朋友有一腿，这里不就是他俩之间的关系嘛。
但是没有那个啊。
我们说呢来。
这个。
这个我们说主角，这是主角的对手。
然后主角的对手的爸爸。
对吧我们说主角这个对手。
嗯。
非常丧心病狂。
一定要这个。
搞我们的主角，为什么呢？是因为他爸爸老虐待他，老揍他。
但是这个对手的爸爸。
跟其他人是没有关系的，跟主角是没有关系的。
只跟这个对手发生关系。
我们说我们在这个图里面要画出来嘛？
就是。
再连连一块呃是不需要的，为啥呢？因为他跟主角之间是完全没有关系的，没有作用力的。
没有直接作用力的那在这里其实它不视为。
不视为配角。
在我们剧本创作中，我们可以视它为道具。
视他为道具。
当然了，拍戏的时候你不能说哎啊。
这个这个这个演员。
演演这个道具，你肯定不这么说，还是当然还是说是角色。但是在我们剧本创作的层面，它是个道具，为啥呢？就于他跟我们主角步伐。
不发生关系。
他就不是配角，他不需要遵守。
配角的。
这个。
这些原则。
特别是不需要加强。
对吧你说他他的父亲呃虐待他，然后呢，所以导致他做事情很偏执，然后阻碍我们的主角。然后呢，他父亲为什么要虐待他呢？是因为他父亲呃年轻的时候婚姻不幸福。那你写一些他父子俩的故事就行了，那跟我们有什么关系啊？
那就卡出去了。
懂这意思吗？没有必要跟主角没有直接。
推力或者主力的角色一律不描写。
他了这个主角配角以及人物关系了啊。
我们接下来讲另外一个概念。
叫人物湖光啊。
人物湖光也叫人物弧线。
这个概念这几年提的也挺狠的，提挺多的。
他其实是一个老词儿。
在最早的教材里面就有它本来是指什么呢？指就是人物啊。
在这个故事中。
1.1点的成长，1.1点的蜕变。
他本来是指这个意思。
但是现在被着重提出来了。
为什么呢？因为大家发现一个问题。
凡是张力大的故事啊。
这个角色的成导。
而且很长。
而且很圆。
等于是啥呢？假设你是一个球体，人性是一个球体的话。
它的起点和终点在球的两端。
而且他不是直着穿过去的。
他是经过一个弧线划过去的。
滑过去的。
比如说。
开始的时候。
他是一个胆小如鼠的人。
那结局的时候。
他就要是一个无所无所畏惧的勇者。
开始的时候，他是一个不负责任的人。
最后结局的时候，他就要是一个勇于担当人。
开始的时候。
他是一个小肚鸡肠的人。
结束的时候，他就是要一个非常。
走1个180度的转变。
我们说这个是用来干嘛？这个往往是用来。
我觉得是用来检查你的人物。
检查你的主角。
是比较有用的。因为咱们写一个故事的时候啊。
其实都是带着。
主角的成长写的。
只不过你有时候写的不那么完整，不那么圆乎。
所以我认为人物湖光这个提法。
主要是呢检查人物。
比较有用。
我为什么提出来讲呢？是因为这个提法现在。
挺流行的，提的人挺多的，所以咱有必要知道一下。
而且有人提说，在一个故事里面啊。
除了坏蛋以外，其他角色都带变为人物。
我觉得有点夸张了，有点夸张。
主要还是你还是考虑主角的成长就可以了。主角的成长和转变配角呢有的因为经历了事儿了，你弟弟。
开始给你把风，后来经历点事儿，对吧？背叛你了，对吧？你女朋友开始给你戴绿帽子，后来发现跟你是真爱，又回归你了，他们这也不叫成长，这就是就是转变而已。
主角的成长是一点1点儿。
你在你的事件从群中，比如说开始小肚鸡肠。
到开始能容忍一点别人。
然后呢，到后来经历一个事儿。
然后在容忍和自我牺牲之间又做出了选择，最后到达完全能包容世界，完全牺牲小我。
他就是他他有个变化过程。
所以我认为啊人物湖光。
必须你定好你的起点和终点，你起点任务。
终点经历完所有的事的时候在哪，然后在中间的环节中给他打几个点，让它变化有层次。
检查一下你的人。
做一下任务。
然后人湖光为什么？
我需要提出来讲呢，因为不怕你们搞困惑。因为现在有些片子是没有人。
比如说系列片。
用咱们中国的话说叫张回体啊。
召回体是没有。
没有人互广。
呃呃呃，这个探案集福尔摩斯探案全集。
他每一集都很聪明。
对吧每一集都很正义。
那不存在什么。
呃，人物弧线。
济公传也是梅集他是。
罗汉真身呀，每一集这个抓一个妖，每一集降一个魔。
他也没有什么明显的人物弧现和成长。
再像那个情景剧。
巡点局也是这样。
情景剧不光没有人物弧线，情景剧的人物关系也是也是固定。
我们说一般戏中的人物关系它是流动，它是变化。
有些人给你阻力，有些人给你呃推力，阻力和推力基本平衡。
然后呢，但是呢有些人可以慢慢从阻力变成推力，有些人从推力变成阻力。
它是变化。
但是情景剧。
不光人物没有弧线。
人物关系也不变。
你知道为啥吗？因为这种剧啊都是系列的，它都有点像张辉体，他要不断的复制批量生产。
你这个角色开始的时候很很胆小，然后呢哦这一集结束或者这一季结束变成了一个很勇敢的人。
走到对面了，180度的一个大弧线。然后明年开始，下一季，他又从最勇敢的人又变成一个最胆小的人。你这来来回回折腾什么呀？
是吧。
情景剧啊它是。
因为电视的发展。
而产生的。我们说故事原本是属于戏戏剧和电影。
你现在电视蓬勃发展。
所以情景剧它是电视的产。
他有点跟谁比较亲连，就是亲戚更近啊，情景剧跟电影。
呃，远。
他跟电视栏目其实关系更近，亲血缘更近。
比如说综艺节目。
综艺节目也是呀，他有一个人设，和有一个人物关系，然后呢就一集一级复制情景剧也是这样，你看生活大爆炸，谢耳朵、笑欧等永远是一个一个。
永远是处理类似的问题，一集一集又一集。
你不觉得就是看这种生活大爆炸，就像看快乐大本营。
何老师负责评事儿，谢娜负责捣乱对吧？杜海涛负责挨欺负，就是他是一套流程。
稳定的人物关系，稳定的人物设定不需要弧线，好吧。
所以说人物湖光大家了解一下为什么呢？用来检查你的人物。
你觉得你的人物没有力量。
你就去去检查一下。
他的成长有没有从一端成长到另外一端，而且这两端还要拉长。
第一端放了第一场戏，最后一端放在最后一场戏。
当中的变化是要有过程的，走满一个完整的人物弧线。
检查你的。
人物好吧。
然后最后我想跟大家说一点什么呢？
就是关于这个呃。
这个角色的名字问题。
哎呀，这个事儿啊。
我也是经常经常发现啊，咱们的这个这个这个初学者呀上来就先给各个角色取名字，哎呀，特别开心。取名字的环节，他好像是他唯一找到创作控制感的，就是我掌控局面的那种感觉的时候，写故事时候不会写，起名字的时候很带劲，你知道吗？起名字的时候相当带劲。
上来就给角色起名字，我说你配角你都先不用写，写的太早了，名字更不用那么早起名字最后起。
但是这个时候你如果写到这个程度了，是是该起的。因为起完名字，你可以更好的跟你的角色。
建立爱呀，建立连接呀。
是应该在这个时候取了。
但起名字我为什么？
按理说啊不应该干涉。
因为他是个很私人的事情，就像你跟你孩子取名字一样，那是你家的事儿，对吧？有些人经常在网上说，我哎呀，我姓什么，我老公姓什么，然后呢争给我孩子争个名，然后啊1万个人在那给他留言。我跟你说，他一个都不会用。
为啥好不容易生一次孩子，他肯定自己想名字，所以按理说我不该干涉。
但是呢你们是我的学生，所以在剧本中起名字，我觉得我有我有。
我有资格叨叨几。
啥呢？就是因为我见过太多学生。
给给给给给角色取名字。
比给自己孩子取名字还过分，为啥？
因为给自己孩子起名字，你姓儿。
是不能动的。
给角色取名字，像也可以随便起。
啊就各显神通了。
我管这种现象啊，就管他就是。
我看这些名字啊。
我总结出一条规律，而且我给这个现象起了一个名字叫琼瑶陷阱。
真的就是穷瑶现金。
所有年轻编剧给他的角色起了名。
你仿佛都在琼瑶剧里面看到。
嘉豪。
你怎么了？嘉豪。
子豪背叛了我。
但我心里依然爱着欣然。
还是子自豪家豪。
呃，那个那个欣然心怡子轩乙轩。
全是这种名字哎。
然后姓什么呢？什么姓什么？姓肖。
姓梁。
姓齐。
姓谭。
全是这种馅儿。
当然比早几年好，早几年那副姓都嗷嗷往上上啊，姓欧阳姓令狐，姓独孤。哎呀，妈呀，你生活中见过一个姓独孤的吗？
是不是那都什么朝代的姓了？
那是鲜卑族的相啊，那对吧。
还还还还在偶像剧里还嗷嗷出呢。
不要这样好吧，不要这样就用。
常见性常见字儿。
起名字。
名字呢要跟角色有一定的。
贴合度要有有一定的贴合度。
嗯。
这其实也不怪大家起名字这玩意儿啊。
啊，不怪大家。
父母给孩子起名字也这样。
你像。
不光这个角色里面是这个这个。
重要陷阱，你去幼儿园看一看，也全是这种名字。
对吧你叫一声子萱，三四个小姑娘回头，还有的家长说，我还跟他们不一样，他们是儿子的子，我是紫树的子，一个木子旁，一个辛苦的辛有什么区别啊，对吧？张子轩是吧？这没有区别。
佳轩佳琦全是这种。
这也是。
这就跟父母的。
呃，这个认知背景是有关系的。
你像啊我父母那边，你看他们叫什么名？
叫什么建国。
胜利。
是吧。
呃，学兵。
对吧还有什么。
呃，这个。
爱英英雄呀是吧？为什么那群民字哪来的？
他们是从哪儿来的？
红歌标语。
战斗口号里面来的，在那个年代，这个是他们最时尚的东西。那听那个听多了，自然而然就起那种。
然后我这辈儿。
我这辈的同学里面什么名字最多？
尾。
另。
对吧张丽、王丽、孙俪。
侠。
云霞。
彩霞。
还有钠。
对吧什么娜张娜李娜。
利娜。
对吧。
才是这种名字。
特别多。
你说这个名字哪来？
七8十年代70年代末，80年代初这这一波名字拿来。
诗歌里面来。
就诗歌里面来的那现在那时候。
解诗的人是最洋气的呀。
海边飘过一朵美丽的云霞。
就是从这这哎呀海丽霞美全部拿过来当名字了，觉得诗哥洋气极了。
然后后来后悔了，一波全是这种名字，对吧？
然后等这个张伟和这个李呃李娜两个人结婚，长大了以后卯了全身的地儿，说我们不能再让孩子有一个太大太大众太俗的名字了。
毕业了半天。
起了个名字叫佳轩。
为什么李嘉轩。
为啥呀？
因为他们看琼瑶剧，看言情小说长大的，他们觉得琼瑶里面的那些人，你侬我侬的那些人的名字是最洋气的。
这就是。
我说的琼瑶陷阱，我们这一代人起名字啊，琼瑶陷阱被琼瑶影响很大。
怎么样避免这个问题啊？
我呃我给大家一个简单的规律。
你就用常用字儿。
不要去用生僻字儿，不要说我起个特别的名字，我就去用生僻字，用常用字儿，但是不常用在名字里的字儿。
这是一种最好。
可以让你的名字既有个性又好记，而且不矫情。
有这样的名字呀，比如说你看现在火的那个李宪。
现在的现。
是很少用在名字里。
但是人家叫。
而且礼仪又是第一大姓，礼宪这名字就很很好听嘛。
还有个名字也很很很很典型，萨顶鼎。
啊。
这名字多好顶。
鼎是很少用在名字里的一个字吧，没有其他任何一个人叫呃张鼎，对吧？孙鼎没有，但是人家用啊就很好。
萨丁丁这名是改的呀。
他原名叫周鹏。
我跟你说，他如果叫周鹏，他火不了。
我们说欢迎歌手周鹏为大家带来一首。
呃，那叫什么万物生。
然后周鹏就出来了，嗯然后我们就哎哎呀，周鹏，你干什么呀？周鹏，你唱了些什么呀？你。
郑鹏，要不你别唱了。
接受不了。
但你看他改的名字，气质就不一样了。
我说下面由萨顶鼎为家大大家带来一首万物生。
判断爱。
穿着一身藏袍。
他的那个小辫儿。
挂点银饰出来，嗯，我们说一我叫钉钉哎呀。
这首歌哎顶顶哎。
有点这个意思啊，顶顶来，顶顶可以顶顶。
你就马上就这这就是名字的魅力啊。
就得用这种你想名字不俗。
而且不跟别人重样，我的建议就是你用。
糖用在名字里。
常用。
就这么一个简单小技巧。
怎么样去找不常用在名字里的常用字呢？说说挺简单的。我给大家一个最简单的办法，我每次起名字都这么用，就找一本书，随便一本书啊，我这就随手拿一本。
呃，冯友兰的这个中国哲学简史。
随便翻译随便翻一页。
看啊随便翻译。
从里面找。
常用字，但不不常用在名字里的。
墨经中的知识论。
是一种。
朴素的实在论。
就这么一句话，比方墨金中的知识论。
知。
嗯。
就很少用在。
名字里吗？
我们说那知我们就可以搞来。
用一下吧。
对吧。
我们说叫。
遵之。
哎，我们说有点担保。
那要孙枝什么吗？
对吧。
尊之一。
你看看这个名字就。
哎，又特别又好记，还跟别别人不一样，绝对不会重名，对吧？那这句话里还是。
是一种。
朴素的实在论。
树。
当然也可以吗？
送。
是吧。
李数。
嗯。
不是又是一个字吗？
是吧。
然后。
一种朴素的实在论。
再这个字儿再常见不过了，但是谁用在名字里了？
在呀。
李在不就是李现的弟弟吗？
李财李现李在兄弟俩。
对吧？
诶这。
你就是用这种常用字，就我给大家提供一个简单思路，我自己就经常这么起名字，你就是用。
翻开一本白话文的书。
随便找一段话，把里面。
那种常用字儿，但是不常用在名字里的，拿过来用。而且我以后再看到这样的名字啊，我就知道哎呀，这是我这个流派的。
是我们自己人对吧？这种名字他就好记，不要去给我找什么哎，肖子轩，对吧？齐天好这种一听哎呀我这一听这个名字我就头大，这个大家一定要注意好吧，这个起名字，这个是这节课加出来的，大家自己去体会。好，下课。